hello my name is Christina Talbert
slagle and i am the senior scientific
officer of the yale global health
Leadership Institute and a lecturer at
the Yale School of Public Health I'm
here today to talk to you about ideas
related to spreading health innovations
in health systems so the ideas here are
about innovation spread and what we're
going to be doing is really taking
lessons from HIV we're actually going to
explore the idea of going viral because
in global health we often have great new
ideas great new health innovations
perhaps a new vaccine perhaps a new
mechanism for birth control but these
innovations are quite challenging to
introduce into an existing system and
spread to other similar systems so we're
thinking about how to implement and
scale up health innovations and our team
has thought very hard about this and
really try to explore the question of
what it means to go viral and can we
learn from looking at a virus like HIV
that has as we know been disastrously
successful at spreading so today I'm
going to take you through what actually
happens when HIV infects a human cell
and spreads to other cells and we're
going to take some steps that will learn
from that process that we can apply to
the ideas of spreading health
innovations in human systems so first
let's look at what a human cell is so
here's our human cell it has a boundary
inside of it is the nucleus and inside
of that nucleus is human DNA now many of
us are familiar with this
characterization of a human cell it
looks kind of like a fried egg this is
somewhat deceptive in its simplicity
this is really kind of two-dimensional
flat in point of fact a human cell is
three-dimensional
incredibly complex inside of human DNA
we have 20,000 genes and these jeans
make many many many hundreds of
thousands of proteins that all interact
inside of this three dimensional system
to maintain it to keep it healthy and to
protect it from things that don't belong
from the outside now as I mentioned
we're thinking about how does a virus
come into these cells become part of the
cell and then spread to others so our
virus is HIV HIV is comparatively much
more simple it only has nine genes many
virologists think that viruses like HIV
outside of a human cell are not even
alive and yet HIV can get into a cell
become part of the DNA of a cell and
then spread to other cells so how does
it do that and that's what I'm going to
go through with you today so just to
make sure we understand the learning
here this virus is going to be analogous
to a health innovation so some of the
things that I mentioned like a new type
of vaccine maybe a different mechanism
for birth control and this cell is the
human health system that we're trying to
change with our innovation so in the
next video I will describe to you how
HIV gets into a cell and how it starts
to make itself a permanent part of this
system and then we'll take some
learnings that might help us when we're
thinking about introducing a health
innovation into an existing system